welcome back at the Dave Ramsey show on
the line is pester Rob McDowell from
North Metro Church in Marietta Georgia
pastor Rob how are you brother I am
doing really really well I'm very
honored and excited that we get to
celebrate our church being debt-free I
love church debt-free screams this is
absolutely awesome so how much has your
church paid off and over what period of
time well we originally we had a new
building project that was 12 million and
we got down to where we only had seven
point six million dollars in debt we
just say only but that's a big amount
you know and I became lead pastor five
years ago and that was my signing bonus
with seven point six million dollars we
we knew that that these were handcuffs
for us we couldn't be the church that
God want us to be until we got these off
of us and so we kind of had a an option
a somebody writes a check for seven
point six million dollars which have
been awesome know what Plan B was let's
pray our guts out and be fully depend
upon the Lord and people just absolutely
just grabbed on to that and in three
years and three months we were able to
pay off the debt that's amazing how many
congregants about 2,300 Wow
that's huge so what caught me hang on I
get it because I'm the get out of debt
math nerd right but what kind of vision
caught them because paid off dad as a
fund raiser it's not not real sexy yeah
you know what we just that was kind of a
burden we had that you know we thought
for a while there to say look this could
be the this could be the Titanic this
ship could sink and but begin to ask
question this numbers--and leadership
that just asked the question that you
know what does does this area need
another church well we even would it
make a difference if we disappeared and
we started to ask the question would we
even be missed if this church just was
wiped off the planet and the people
in it would we even be missed and so we
just kind of prayed and asked the
question and made the statement yes you
know what we we want to be the kind of
church that would actually be missed if
we weren't here and so we just took it
from there and we we talked about there
are things that we could that we must do
and there was things that we could do
but then there's things that we that I'm
sorry that we should do but then we
could do and that could do stuff is a
huge amount of stuff but we can't do it
as long as we're in debt and so the
first thing that we must do is we had to
get out of debt and it was just an
unbelievably just amazing work of God's
kindness and is favored towards us just
moving through the generosity of so many
people it's a strange thing when people
act how God acts I mean it's just this
this weird combination of it's not up to
us but it is up to us and it's not up to
God but it is up to him and this this
mixing of that is just sowing and
reaping and you know and then God makes
it rain and so there's this mix of these
two things that are just beautiful when
they unfold it's a fabulous canvas so
one of the most amazing things I've seen
now very very cool so what happened with
the individual families inside the
church did it change them yes it did as
a matter of fact we've had a number of
people I mean hundreds of people have
actually gone through SPU we've been
offering that for years paying off I
mean each class paying off tens of
thousands of dollars of debt and
hundreds of thousand dollars over the
course of all those years and so I think
it's just gotten people giving them a
vision of what we can do as a church but
also putting it out there what they
could do in their own lives yeah they
actually were able to get debt-free so
it's been it's been quite contagious
very cool that is very very cool well
I'm proud of you guys congratulations
it's got a field on right it feels
amazing that is the real it's it's
really good numbers I mean three point
three years to pay off seven point six
million with 2,300 attenders that's
that's pretty strong I mean I do this a
lot and these those numbers are per head
is that that's sacrificial it's really
strong really everybody got involved and
put their shoulder to the wheel very
well that's that's another thing we've
seen it's just we saw more people
beginning to give for the first time
trusting God with their finances and so
stories have just been amazing very very
neat well pastor Rob it's an honor to
talk to you thank Rob McDowell pastor of
North Metro Church Marietta Georgia any
words for other pastors out there that
are facing the same kind thing you are
you were yeah I would say that there's
moments when you think that it would be
impossible and the lack of would say
there's no way you can do that but we
are have been living proof of the
kindness and faithfulness of God and so
never say never and just put it to your
people and I'd say watch God do what he
always does yeah absolutely fabulous and
we've got some great video / audio of
the church gathering to do their
debt-free scream so I'll let you count
it down and the team in the booth will
fire it alright here we go three two one
that's North Metro Church Marietta
Georgia seven point six million dollars
paid off in three years and three months
man they leaned into that that's strong
very well done
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here I hope
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you